i thought they were lesbians they're
just married to them
[Music]
look at this cute ass couple and when i
say i'm talking about the girl
specifically not you so much
[ __ ]
i am i'm more astonished
how you did this
that is [ __ ] crazy right
who knows who the [ __ ] thought that was
happening
you got a great job huh
so she put her head in his lap as soon
as i said it she was like yeah i
probably own some head he makes a lot of
money
it was instinctive but she was like yeah
[ __ ] this guy's rich i forgot
what do you do for a living
financial technology is that what that
is
son
what the [ __ ] does that mean
see how that was vegas [ __ ]
blending the business with the
technology that's a ponzi scheme made
off i know
i know hey all of a sudden you make
sense
[ __ ] ernie made off over here
i knew something was up
what do you do for fun i bet it's a lot
of rich ass activities yachts
don't tell me you don't be yeah i
[ __ ] told you
i am good at judgment guys
they say don't judge a book by his cover
that cover let me know everything i need
to know right there
that financed girl and that regular ass
guy that [ __ ] made sense
that's an expensive ass book
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you okay you don't look happy to see
me at all either that's a [ __ ] you yo
you yeah you sit next to the mic like
you about to make a psa like i don't
find this funny
that's not astonishing to you this girl
and that guy
no fun over here
[ __ ] look at this boring [ __ ] she
loves him i'm sure she does it helps
that he's rich that's all i'm saying
and i'm not picking on you like i don't
know my situation is very similar my
wife is objectively gorgeous
me nah
so that's what you got to do i got to
work my ass off and then every time she
starts looking at me and she starts
assessing my beauty i just throw a bag
at that [ __ ]
chess
how are you ma'am are you here by
yourself i would love that actually
what the [ __ ] they treating you like
this for yo
ass foul dawg
this [ __ ] they need to be by herself i
think
no fun-ass girl
this girl no fun
she's sitting here just spreading her
shitty entity over their arms crossed
what's wrong with that
hey you guys need this girl in your
corner right
i love when people come to the show
alone i think that's a beautiful thing
is confident i love that but now i feel
bad they just put you on a [ __ ]
island
let's cast you off like gilligan
why you had to move
oh i'm sorry because of me hey
what the [ __ ] is that
oh cause of you because you had to come
entertain us
you paid money for that that exact thing
you know sometimes i say i could judge a
book by his cover
that's a single cover let's be
[Applause]
honest beautiful it's not because you're
not attractive it's cause you say [ __ ]
like that
because of you [ __ ] is that yo
what's she yelling me for i'm married i
get all the yelling i need i need to
come to my job have some other [ __ ]
yelling at me
i'm a one [ __ ] yell at human being i'm
faithful to my wife that's the only
[ __ ] they're ever yelling me ever i
never cheat yell at this [ __ ] i never
do that
let somebody else yell at me that's
[ __ ] traitorous
yo only one woman gets to make my life
miserable
is not you
you guys are still dating huh
you're engaged oh congrats dude the
shitty ass audience don't even care
that's you that's your fault it's
contagious
this guy
come on
what a winner [ __ ] me
what a winner this guy is
oh [ __ ]
what did your dad do for a living
why don't i want to know
mafia
you think a mafia dad is going to let
his son enter fintech
you know how hard it is for a mafia dad
have a gay son come on
nobody wants that
i'm not saying he's homosexual but i'm
saying to a mafia guy fintech
embarrassing dog kill somebody
make your dad proud
all right okay i see you can i pick this
up am i allowed to touch this look at
what he got his girl god damn
yeah
thank god you got it because otherwise i
was gonna be like who did you [ __ ] that
you had to buy her this bag
[Laughter]
that is a relief that you bought that
yourself
oh my god
what's the nicest gift he's bought you
wow she looked at she i swear to got you
this
she in that moment was like i could do
better than this [ __ ] i bet
what did she say
children well that is yo that's some
[ __ ] that a woman would say about what
she got her man that's how much you
ain't [ __ ] is that's when you don't when
you don't get your man [ __ ] you're like
what you give your man she's like kids
and then you can't be like you cheap
[ __ ] cause she won she gave you kids he
didn't give you the kids by the way did
he give birth to the [ __ ] you
gave the kids have some self-esteem girl
that was your hard work this
[ __ ] just nutted in you
[Applause]
he don't get credit for the kids he gave
you one chromosome you did everything
else
how hard is that for a man hey hey just
don't pull out oh
[Laughter]
oh i don't know if i'll be able to get
through this one
and i don't say i never gave you
anything
you are a [ __ ] great wife dude you
are a great wife i judge the [ __ ] out of
this guy right now yeah i know you were
pardoned i'm trying to figure out why
you with her why did she settle bro tell
me a good reason she's with you
you're a [ __ ] boss why don't you buy
her some gifts boss
what kind of slave labor employee you
got here
boss
[Laughter]
that was good though you thought that
quickly i didn't i was putting you on
the spot and you had a hard ass answer
up front but you don't know i ask
questions after questions that's the
thing i do i'm a big fan of this girl
best gift he gave me cost no money
cost me nine months of [ __ ] my entire
life and body and hormones
what a great guy
[Laughter]
hey look at this classy ass couple i bet
you bought her something nice what's the
nicest gift you bought her watch you
about to not look like [ __ ] i hope
you brought her here
you a cheap [ __ ] bro that's god
[Laughter]
damn the best gift you ever got here got
a two-drink minimum what you doing
what is that
how is that a good gift
[Laughter]
you gave her the gift of laughter i gave
her the gift of laughter
[Applause]
god damn do a lot of ancient guys up
here man you guys seem like you're the
[ __ ] power couple you seem like the
trophy husband and you
right my man is the trophy husband
well i called him good looking i didn't
say [ __ ] participation trophy that
would have been [ __ ] up i didn't say
that that would have been messed up i
say a good looking guy you know
what about you you guys seem like the
adorable couple you got a [ __ ] i never
seen a black woman wearing a ben and
jerry shirt in my life
this blows my mind dude
ain't that crazy
i didn't even know black people could
eat lactose like that to be honest with
you i thought that was
[Laughter]
i thought that was a thing because i
know indians have a little trouble
you guys do seem sweet i swear to god
you guys seem like such sweet people
what's the best gift you got your wife
brand new that's what i'm [ __ ]
talking about hey hey jesus
you heard that toyota camry [ __ ]
i know that this he bought his wife a
toyota camry
i know that [ __ ] here you go baby gives
great gas mileage
but it really maintains its resale value
it's a little very low maintenance
brand new car dude that's a [ __ ]
keeper right there you guys love you
guys you guys dressed up i appreciate
that y'all came twice i like half of you
i was listen you tried to be nice and i
was really sweet of you but it made him
look like such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
wow
what do you do miss
i knew i knew you were a doctor or
almost
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh man
y'all little funny dizzy couple dude i
never seen an indian so proud of not
making it as a doctor
ain't that funny
oh man that's good dude
you guys are fun
y'all are dating i assume
yeah i can tell because you still got
your hand on the inside of her thigh
that's a dating move
that's a dating ass move
how long have you all been dating
nine months okay that's how long it took
his gift to form
[Applause]
oh my god dude
what a terrible answer that was
it was a really sweet answer but it was
so bad
he could be so mad at you after the show
hey guys you're adorable
you couple also
ah dude that would have been fire
[ __ ] i wish
lesbian asians in the corner of the room
out of myself [ __ ] fire
just friends
are you guys in your own relationships
you are okay married
good for you healthy relationship right
there
friday night you let her go out with
your friend he's at home chilling i hope
he's at home right
[Applause]
where is he oh
softball oh
what a queer come on softball
i thought they were lesbians they're
just married to them
[Laughter]
oh boy
i am having fun with you guys holy [ __ ]
i have another show after this i'm not
gonna like them as much and i'm gonna
hate you guys for it later i'm gonna be
like they were too fun
okay so your husband is playing softball
on a friday night that's a good dude
okay does he have any um softball
friends you can set her up with
obviously most of them are gay but maybe
there's one outlier
is he also asian descent what is he
jewish oh okay
i was going to say if he had immigrant
parents that'd be tough to explain
i'm going to play softball you know what
i mean
they would be like what the [ __ ] is
softball and then you you'd have to tell
them it's baseball for homosexuals and
it's like a tough thing
it's a tough thing to do you know you
had to come out of the closet and tell
them
oh man
[Laughter]
how are you guys you guys are a couple i
assume
yeah yeah yeah
she said no he said yeah that's
embarrassing yo
why are you doing that to him dude
how did y'all meet
yeah that's what's up little me too
situation i like that
where did you guys work
at writing oh that's a job you could
lose never mind that [ __ ] is
that's not even forbidden romance they
were both looking at each other like you
want to get unemployment together how
about we do that
i'm sick of this [ __ ]
were you pharmacists or what yeah okay i
guess that cause you're indian i was
like it's got to be
an explanation
i think it can't just be
[ __ ] indian cashier you're not
disappointed i'll be
if i saw indian cashier i would
immediately go get a sympathy card for
his parents
get well soon
condolences sorry for your loss
oh man so you're both pharmacists
why you gotta answer so extra all the
time this [ __ ] is of course that's the
only way it's yo
you guys got kids
it's a lot right i'm not
i'm not imagining this
are you sure you don't have two reds
do you have two red syndrome
she lacked a little bit like two rats
right
you have kids no
look at this indian couple trying to
distance from you guys
afraid this [ __ ] is contagious
this is the most jersey indian ever seen
in my life dog oh my god bro
[Applause]
huh
get the [ __ ] out of here this
[ __ ] don't look like you
straight out of edison
[Applause]
you might have grew up in queens but you
spent a lot of time on oak tree road
i'll tell you that [ __ ] right now
i know this [ __ ] been to dimple
bombay talk many times
old mitas ass boy i know
are you also indian miss you could go
either way
huh
you're west indian oh now it all makes
sense okay
west indians are really proud of not
being indian
and it makes me laugh because it's like
you guys took the second dumbest boat
ride
how do you let white people get such a
good deal on you that's [ __ ] up man
y'all not even india you're right you
not indian we never would have fallen
for that [ __ ] that was
addition by subtraction that's what that
was
[Laughter]
you got a sleeve tattoo
[ __ ] yo what are you guyanese
yeah i knew
no indian trinny would let his son do
that [ __ ]
that's guyanese only
what do you do for a living it's
probably not an indian job but you ain't
no [ __ ] pharmacist
fireman yeah yeah
so your guyanese who looks indian has
the job of an italian
guy got a real identity crisis
what is your job mrs indian indian
you're a nurse
[Applause]
i swear to god you know i know she's a
nurse because she got a cross on her
neck
and if you guys don't know if you see a
south indian woman malu christian woman
that [ __ ] a nurse every [ __ ] time
right
bright indian table every [ __ ] time
y'all
they're like our filipinos
oh man
you guys are still in the lead as my
favorite couple
how you doing man what do you do for a
living you look like a [ __ ]
construction worker
what is a distribution company
right i don't mean nothing yo he tried
to say convenience source first because
he knows i know some people who own
convenience stores
he knows and he was trying to like get
me on his good side
oh yeah arlene's mom owns gas stations
yeah okay maybe you wanna help her i
don't give a [ __ ]
if you ask every person their job
there's a few real ones teachers doctors
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
oh my god
oh they got me dude that was such
[ __ ] good timing
oh [ __ ]
oh man that was so funny great timing
fake job all of it you hit every
you hit every metric for funny
oh you're just getting better and better
by the minute and you make less and less
sense i'm gonna be honest
what does your husband do
oh [ __ ] what restaurants
oh you started talking real yeah i love
taqueria yo
i'm gonna be honest i never been so
wrong in my [ __ ] life
yeah great dude
i love taqueria yo i'm trying to get
free [ __ ] that's why i'm being nice to
him
i know i'm [ __ ] up i know i [ __ ] up
it's on me dude [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
it wasn't worth it
oh all right [ __ ] dude oh my god how
long y'all been married 10 years did he
have the taqueria when you married him
you took a chance and it worked out
good for you
and he had to stick with you even after
you couldn't get a good enough score on
your mcat
what part
oh that's why you're so standoffish
there's a lot of bronx energy figuring
out why i was like what her arm
two hours straight i was like what's
that about
who's offended you
you from the bronx nah but you hey
you're one of the good ones
see she's still [ __ ] talking nobody
talking to her
is there's something you're a lot of fun
i'd never want to talk to you after this
show but i had a lot of fun with you
can you imagine that's your doctor what
type of doctors are you
family medicine y'all ain't doctor
hey
hey you might as well say a podiatry
bruh
y'all are damn near secretaries
oh she's real mad right now look at that
but she know i'm right though but you
know i'm right every time you go to a
family practice doctor all i do is refer
you to somebody that's the secretary
not because they're women it's because
they don't play hey doc something's
wrong with me let me refer you to this
guy that's all they do
out here giving flu shots get the [ __ ]
out of here yo hey come on uh
[ __ ] man what's that clinic
called one step above from working at a
cvs
[Music]
she's real mad too look at her
she's like trying to jlo out here she's
still she's still picked up from the
[Music]
my
bronx
oh my god
hey
give it up for the hasbrook heights city
md they all came to the show
[Laughter]
if you guys watch your booster shots is
where you go
[ __ ] that they're giving you johnson and
johnson that's all they got
i can't believe you said you were
doctors
you could pull that [ __ ] with white
people not three indians no [ __ ]
chance dog
she's so mad it's so funny
this is this is doctors with borders
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]